all right the las vegas real estate
market for lack of a better term is
crazy right now we got an update from
our expert harvey blankfeld
[Music]
welcome to our show this is las vegas
real estate now where we bring the three
e's educate
empower and engage i'm your host harvey
blankfell of the blankfell group at
berkshire hathaway home services and we
have over a century
of collective experience we have a
special guest today we have rocky
thieves here from channel 8 welcome
rocky thank you glad to be here again
glad to have you back
so what's going on in the market you
know the market's crazy right now uh
with
some people saying it's bananas or
whatever you want to call it but this
past weekend i had a good example of
what
sellers need to do to make sure they're
maximizing their
their listings and getting the best deal
in a multiple offer situation we had a
seller
listed in the 700 low 700s nice home
beautiful home
and we thought we were a little
overpriced but we thought we could get
it
we ended up corralling all of our buyers
over the weekend
and we made a decision on monday morning
to pick the very best offer we ended up
going back to the two highest offers and
saying to them hey guys
just tell me what your best offer is
number wise because the terms were
already laid out
and one of them came back at a huge
number and one came back at a slightly
lesser number
but they both had an opportunity i
wanted both of them have the opportunity
for
their sake and also for my seller's sake
and then we ended up choosing of course
the one with a bigger number all the
other terms were equal
and so that's how it is right now that's
what this market is doing
okay so when it comes to competition
though you know you've got all these
buyers and all these people that want
your home
what do you do with them how do you get
them to compete at the highest rate
okay so once you go to your mark once
you go to market make sure your home is
available as much as possible
make the availability there as much as
possible but what we like to do is we
have to kind of structure the showings
so that the buyers see each other coming
and going
sometimes we've seen this we've seen
lines in and out of listings but we do
it almost intentionally to a certain
extent so that they know
there's competition hey we really want
this house we're gonna have to step up
in a big way to get it what should the
seller
do with their home should they make sure
it's clean should they make sure it's
you know what's the checklist
that's a great question rocky you know
there's an inclination to believe that
hey i'm just going to put on the market
i'm just getting a great number throw it
out there
you still need to get it clean you need
to get it decluttered
if you want to maximize your return you
want to show your house in the best
possible light
as though it's a model home in a normal
market we might be saying gee i hope i
get list or close to list
in this market we're seeing how far
above this can i go
and if i if i declutter and i clean and
i make sure everything's working
properly
maybe i'll go 10 over list i mean we're
seeing that
pretty often right now right and the
goal is to get multiple offers right
it sure is right now in this market if
you're not getting multiple offers
there's something wrong
okay well what's the future what are you
what are you predicting for
the coming weeks i think we're going to
see more of the same for the balance of
the year i don't really see the market
turning in any one direction
uh las vegas is a popular place to live
right now there's lots of people moving
here from california and around the
country
so i love where we're situated right now
i'm very bullish on our market and
continue to grow
there's people who are fearful that
we're overpriced we're really not we're
right on course
over history we're right where we're
supposed to be all right give harvey and
his team a call at 702-203-1165 or visit
lvrealestateradio.com las vegas